dans le centre de la france en auvergne
des rafales ont atteint près de 160
kilomètres heure en portant le toit de
la tour de contrôle de l'aéroport de
clermont ferrand
une dizaine de personnes ont été
blessées dans le puy-de-dôme pour france
2 agnès garder thierry monnier se sont
rendus dans les monts du livradois à
saint germain l'herm village victimes de
la tempête où la solidarité des
habitants n'est pas un vain mot
d'habitude ce tracteur certes au labour
aujourd'hui ils aident les hommes à
nettoyer les routes à la première heure
ils se sont mis au travail
cinq agents de la dde et autant de
bénévoles du village tout proche
ben mulroney un coup de main c'est
normal faut bien aider aux collègues
alors oui c'est partout j'ai des voix
aussi alors je fais mal au coeur c'est
vrai ici les arbres se ramassent à la
pelle mécanique par centaines et il
faudra des jours avant que toutes ces
petites routes des monts du livradois
soit à nouveau carrossable même chose
pour les fils électriques pour la
plupart les poteaux n'ont pas résisté à
la tempête
un peu partout l'électricité manque dans
le village de saint germain l'herm
on ne met pas ou presque plus le nez
dehors excepté pour quelques rares
commission depuis ce matin brigitte
c'est que la journée sera courte sans
lumière sans outil on ne peut pas faire
du bon travail
ah ben non ça marche que les filets à
leur demande dans du miel béton peut pas
arriver à eybens pour l'instant elle est
arrivée hier soir venir mais tout de
même dit autre préoccupation comment
s'éclairer comment se chauffer les
habitants n'ont qu'une crainte c'est que
la coupure d'électricité s'éternise au
village seuls les anciens sont préparés
au pire
comment vous faites pour chauffer et
bien que le point
c'est à dire montrez-nous elle doit
fermer ce soir la température est
descendue à -5 degrés dans le village
la nuit promet d'être froide très froide